et on va parler de cette affaire avec
jérôme marty est médecin et président du
syndicat union française pour une
médecine libre jérôme marty bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors selon à nos confrères de
libération le gouvernement était au
courant d'un manque de masques d'une
pénurie même comment vous réagissez à
cette information la mal comment
voulez-vous qu'on réagisse l'idée on est
on avait on avait 20 ans quand même de
ce courrier du fait qu'ils étaient
parfaitement au courant les leurs leur
explication qui dure en fait depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines et qu'ils
font devant la commission denquête sont
totalement à côté à côté des réalités
sans leur on le sait très bien
on sait bien que cette crise a traversé
plusieurs mandatures mais ce
gouvernement ne peut pas s'exonérer des
fautes qu'il a commises en ne sachant
pas réagir et prévoir et ça c'est
extrêmement grave parce que ceux qui ont
payé au final au bout de ligne ce sont à
la fois les soignant et les patients
il y a eu des morts qui pouvaient être
des morts évitables
il y a eu quantité de soignants
contaminés
certains y ont laissé la vie mais aussi
et c'est une écoute tous ces drames
pouvait être évitable si vous avez eu
les moyens de protection alors à propos
des masques périmés jérôme salon s'était
déclarée extrêmement surpris comment
vous réagissez en sachant cela
aujourd'hui
non mais jérôme sert le moins se fout de
nous on va dire les choses clairement et
on n'est pas là pour contrer notre duo
jérôme simplement il était responsable
de la sécurité sanitaire du gouvernement
de précédent pour pour madame maryse
pour la ministre marisol touraine ce qui
veut dire qu'il était responsable
précisément de la gestion des stocks et
de la gestion des moyens dans le cadre
de crise pouvant donc frappé le pays
donc cet homme ne peut pas jouer les
janus en permanence aux deux visages
il faut quand même qu'ils soient qu'ils
qu'ils soient à la fois digne de sa
fonction
et puis qu'ils osent aborder la vérité
et pas tourné autour du pot comme il le
fait je veux dire les les îles
ce que l'on a vu dans de lui que d
autres responsables directs de cette
crise sont éminemment pathétique
les hésitations le fait de ne pas
vraiment répondre aux questions enfin je
veux dire on a 49 morts loucher
l'échelle et chez les médecins et chez
les médecins libéraux il ya des morts
des morts chez les soignants hospitalier
aussi la quantité de patients qui ont
laissé la vie il ya des drames il ya
plein de gens s'interrogent aujourd'hui
et on a des gens qui cherchent encore
soit se protéger soi en tout cas un côté
ne pas irriter
ça suffit j'ai mon fils était cette
lettre date d'il ya deux ans il ya deux
ans c'était aussi compliqué ne de
prévoir une telle épidémie nan nan mais
gouverner c'est prévoir
vous le savez comme moi et puis et puis
les lectrices nous savons tous nous
sommes nous sommes des soignants nous
savons très bien et que la phrase peut
rencontrer le ce type d'épidémie nous
savons traiter que ce type de crise
arrive y arrivera de plus en plus
fréquemment
donc il faut prévoir les choses l'ailé
ce qui est terrible là c'est que nous en
venions tente de nous faire croire que
on a été surpris ce sont leurs propres
mots on a été surpris de la situation
que nous avons découvert attendez quoi
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
la réserve sanitaire ça fait partie de
ces parties du pays il y avait les
prises auparavant qui fait partie aussi
de la gouvernance du soin et des stocks
tant matérielles comme personnel que ces
choses-là sont connus il ya des gens
dont c'est le métier que de réaliser des
signaux faibles autant que d'analyser
les manques potentiel par rapport à une
crise
enfin je veux dire un au no et moi je
suis juste généralistes enfin il me
semble quand même que logiquement on est
un pays structuré donc on va pas nous
faire croire qu'on découvre une
situation
mais alors comment on va faire est un
des projets de centrales nucléaires
n'est pas loin de chez moi
on fait comment ils y sont volés
comprimé diodes aussi on va pas vous
dire quand même si jamais il ya encore
un cas d'accident d'une centrale
nucléaire
tout dépôt de découvrir la foi de
comprimés diaw devons protéger la
population
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
jérôme marty
vous qui êtes médecin généraliste sur le
terrain est-ce que déjà vous vous seriez
éventuellement équipe et si une deuxième
vague arriver là maintenant on a un peu
plus tôt même de masse que l'on a pu
avoir la durée de la crise mais on n'a
toujours pas de masques ffp2 de masques
de protection respiratoire qui sauve le
savez les masques qui protège réellement
les soignantes puisque l'on sait que
cette affection aérosols is comedy le
gouvernement puisque pendant longtemps
là aussi on à ergoter tourner autour du
pot en essayant de masquer le fait qu'il
pouvait y avoir une aérosols isation et
que donc il fallait des masques ffp2
plus que des masques chirurgicaux
là on a toujours pas assez de masques
ffp2 donc ce qu'il faut espérer c'est
que ces fameux masques ffp2 vont être
disponibles parce que tout est à
craindre
quant à la possible reprise du le
deuxième bague tout cas d'un retour de
ce virus
une réémergence comme cela se produit
souvent avec d'autres virus dont il faut
effectivement que l'on soit prêt et rai
tre près ça veut dire masques
chirurgicaux
ça veut dire masques ffp2 ça veut dire
test capacité le test solution
hydroalcoolique surblouse écran de
protection avec 7 et mac ou de matériel
de protection dont on a pu manquer et
qui sont à rien qui est un gourmand
corps pour certaines de ces catégories
les blues l'ailé / news7 convaincant et
la maintenance de pénurie dedans on a
plus de gants merci beaucoup jérôme
martyrs d'avoir été avec nous et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france rappelle que vous êtes un médecin
et président du syndicat union française
pour une médecine libre merci beaucoup